this video is brought to you by news
voice the news is broken
almost all US media is owned by just a
handful of big corporations fake news
also obviously a huge problem and
finding something unbiased can be hard
news voice is revolutionising the news
landscape it's an app that gives you a
personalized news feed by aggregating
major news sites as well as
international and independent media
giving some much-needed balance each
news story shows multiple sources which
are all tagged with their bias and
perspective the news affects almost
everything in our lives what we hear and
read shapes which persons we trust what
we eat what we buy how we vote and even
how we think news voices created by its
readers you can upload stories that you
find interesting so more people will see
them is essentially a democratized
platform for the news plus it saves you
time you get the news and all the
sources in one app so that you can be
better informed and it's totally free
anyway get started with news voice today
for free like I said through the link
below it's available on both Google Play
and the App Store and let's get into it
I'm sure many of you have wondered why
there are countries with such strange
shapes for example have you noticed how
weird the outline of Croatia is why does
it have that kind of bang coming down
from it it may sound silly but that Fang
maids Bosnia and Herzegovina landlocked
so what about Russia why do they have
this kind of islands between Lithuania
and Poland
I mean whoever decided that this region
which by the way is called Callan grads
is Russia but the - that really takes
the prize without a doubt the country's
was the strangest shapes are Armenia and
Azerbaijan if you look closely you will
see that Azerbaijan has a strip of lands
on the east side of Armenia but within
azerbaijan itself there is another
region that is in fact controlled by
armenia as you can imagine all of this
is more than lines on a map we're
talking about one of the most complex
conflicts in world politics a conflict
that may be about to be resolved this
video has been made possible by the
Munich Security Conference but not only
because they collaborated with us it's
also that they're an important part of
this whole story at the end of the video
you will have a much better
understanding about how these borders
get drawn so let's get on with our store
[Applause]
[Music]
Armenia and Azerbaijan are two of those
countries that you only hear mentions in
the Eurovision Song Contest and well
here on visual politic these two
countries are neighbors and have a lot
in common both were Soviet republics
both countries are extremely corrupt as
mahjongg is the private confines of the
Alia family and armenia has been run for
decades by an elite group of oligarchs
as if that were not enough in both
countries they speak unpronounceable
languages to give you an idea armenians
have their own type of calligraphy
distinct from any other language in the
world but with so many similarities
between the two countries many will
think oh I'm sure I get a lot right well
Armenia and Azerbaijan hate each other
really hate each other the conflicts
between these two countries has cost
thousands of lives over the past three
decades and caused millions of people to
be displaced
you might be thinking why have I never
heard of this well that's basically
because there are no left or right wings
here instead Russia has always been
supporting the Armenians and Turkey s
Bashar knees the United States has no
interest in this story and since there
are no good guys here the victims don't
get that much attention at this point
many of you will be wondering why it is
that they hate each other so much is it
a matter of ideologies is it because of
Natural Resources well neither of those
it is true that Armenians are Christians
and Azerbaijan is also called as Arion
Muslims but religion is not the reason
the subject of discord is this piece of
land that you see here
[Music]
this region here is called the Goro Cara
bar and it has about 140,000 inhabitants
of which 90% speak armenian armenia says
that it belongs to them but officially
it belongs to azerbaijan
so what's in that region does it have
our oil no is it of any strategic
importance minimal so why are we telling
you this story here on visual politics
well for three reasons the first is
because this conflict may soon be
resolved the second is because we have
had the privilege of watching one of the
episodes of this story play out live so
as you might know visual politic was one
of the media outlets that was invited to
go to the Munich Security Conference and
right at the hotel where this conference
was held with one of the peace talks
this is one of those stories that proves
how absurd politics can often be because
yes here we are talking about two
countries killing themselves for a piece
of land that is basically worth
absolutely nothing it has no oil no
strategic value nothing I think looking
at this issue might help many of us to
realize how absurd many debates are in
which sides just become rigid in
defending a particular stance so what is
going on between Armenia and Azerbaijan
why do they hate each other so much does
the conflict have a solution well today
we're going to answer these questions
but first let's take a look back at the
history
there's a piece no one wanted there
really the question is is who is in
nagorno-karabakh first Armenians or the
Azerbaijanis then you can probably guess
the answer dependency you ask what we do
know is that throughout the 1920s the
majority of the population was Armenian
this is when Stalin arrives in conquered
the entire region then divided it into
three socialist republics Georgia
Armenia and Azerbaijan and what did
Stalin's division do well just what he'd
wished so in 1923 Stalin said this
nagorno-karabakh thing is going to be a
part of Azerbaijan why well because I
said so I'm Stalin everyone else can
sort of just shut up the Soviet Union
never really looked when it came to
drawing borders and no ethnic group or
nationalist movement dared to question
Moscow's decisions so until 1987 no one
dared to say that they wanted to be a
part of Armenia but what happened in
well the Soviet Union was starting to
disintegrate and all of a sudden a whole
lot of Armenians organized a referendum
on self-determination to get out of
Azerbaijan and if possible to be part of
Armenia as you can imagine this sparked
a famous war between Armenia and
Azerbaijan which lasted until 1994
six years of war that took the lives of
more than 30,000 people and left more
than a million displaced so who won the
war when I practice we can say that
Armenia did officially in
nagorno-karabakh is part of Azerbaijan
but the reality is that the region is
ruled by the Republic of Artsakh where
the language the currency and even the
banks are the same as in Armenia
[Music]
and as if this were not enough all of
the borders of this area are controlled
by the Armenian army although almost no
country recognizes arts are castes an
Armenian region in practice it is one
and you're probably thinking what about
the Azerbaijanis who live there well the
truth is almost everyone had to leave
after the war if we count up those who
live in this region and those who lived
in Armenia we're talking about a total
of 800,000 Azerbaijanis and it was a
similar story with the Armenians who
lived in Azerbaijan conclusion well to
this day both peoples hate each other
and I'm really not exaggerating here's
an example in 2005 the then mayor of
Baku the capital of Azerbaijan had an
official meeting with a German
delegation watch out for this gem of
diplomacy you can't miss it
our goal is the complete elimination of
Armenians you Nazis already eliminated
the Jews in the 1930s and 40s right you
should be able to understand us
hajjabdullah Abu Talib of mayor of Baku
in 2005 some of you will be thinking
okay but that guy was just a mayor
what does he matter well take a look at
the current residents of Azerbaijan
ahum Ali F our main enemies are Armenian
's of the world and hypocritical and
corrupt politicians under their control
Ilan Mali of Azerbaijan president if
you're a regular visual politic follower
Ali herbs name is familiar you know
we're talking about a corrupt dictator
with few rivals and as you know corrupt
dictators love to point out the enemy
the Yanks Jews or in this case the
Armenians and that helps to explain why
every time someone has sat down to
negotiate a peace agreements they failed
let's be honest neither side wants peace
and you're probably thinking surely
there must be some possible agreements
well of course
in 2009 the Organization for Security
and Cooperation in Europe sat ally Evans
he then president of Armenia
down at the same table why did they do
it in Madrid that's where they set out a
series of principles
basically the inhabitants of nagura
Karabakh or if you prefer the Republic
of Arts I could decide whether they
wanted their land to be a part of
Armenia or Azerbaijan the Armenian army
who would have to withdraw from the
surrounding areas and Azerbaijan would
guarantee a corridor between this region
and Armenia it makes sense doesn't it
well yes on paper it does make a lot of
sense but unfortunately neither side was
willing to accept it at the end of the
day having an archrival has been a great
blessing to the oligarchs of both
countries however now things could be
set to change why well we're gonna look
into that right now
the armenian outsider armenia is one of
the few countries in the world that has
more citizens outside of its borders
than inside as it stands today some 3
million people live within our means but
the armenian diaspora totals more than
10 million people so why are so many
people leaving the country well at home
they have more than 20% unemployment
they have the same per capita income as
namibia and corruption is around every
corner and once again the conflict in
nagorno-karabakh is the perfect
scapegoat for all of its problems
what's more almost all the political
elite come from this country in fact the
former Armenian Prime Minister was born
in the Republic of our sac the former
prime minister of Armenia was also born
in the Republic of Arts Atkins the same
goes a lot of senior officials and
believe me strange as it may seem the
blissful Republic of Arts a kiss of a
number-one priority of all the
governments this country has had
[Music]
Armenia might have all the corruption
you can imagine but it's presidents did
such useful things as trying to convince
the government of Tuvalu to recognize
artac as an independent republic yep
that's right
Tuvalu one of those tiny forgotten
countries in the Pacific man's the list
goes on today there are six states in
the United States that recognize the
Republic of Arts ACK and you're probably
seen in individual states within the
United States I mean what business does
California have recognizing sovereign
states
well nothing that's how a lot of
Armenian politicians have been
justifying their paycheck for years
until we get to 2018 Union protestors
brought down a prime minister Washington
Post exactly we covered this here on
visual politic in 2018 the Armenians had
had enough of so many years of
corruption abuse of power and the
poverty that is consequence of such a
situation and they drove their prime
minister out the new Armenian government
is led by the man you see on screen
nickel passion yeah in his first two
years of rule and has carried out
several economic reforms and appears to
be fighting corruption seriously and
you're probably gonna say well so what
does this man think of the conflict well
this probably won't surprise
a chignon calls for unification between
Armenia and Karabakh your raisinet I
know what you're probably thinking
that's hardly original these days right
well yes and no at the same time first
passion Yan is the first Prime Minister
in years not to be born in that region
seconds he is an absolute outsider when
it comes to the Armenian elites in other
words he doesn't need to fuel the fear
of Azerbaijan to gain popularity and
that's why it's an opportune moment
negotiate a peace agreement the question
is how exactly our peace agreements
negotiated well let's take a look
[Music]
the Munich Security Conference imagine
for a moment that you have been hired as
an advisor to the Armenian government
and you want to negotiate with
Azerbaijan well where would you start
maybe had tried to get the phone number
set back whose presidential palace and
call them up and just ask if Ali was
there chances are that they're gonna
hang up the phone that's what political
conferences are for that's where
political leaders from all over the
world come together and they can talk
one-to-one face-to-face well the Munich
Security Conference is one of the
largest of those and you know what's
also part of our mission is to offer a
relatively easy platform for people who
normally find it very hard to visit each
other's country because that is often
seen as a as a as a you know as a
difficult step you lose face by going to
see your adversary so they come to
Munich and they meet here the gentleman
you just saw is Wolfgang
Ishika as the director of the Munich
Security Conference basically here in
this team have a list of names and
numbers of all the politicians who are
going to attend the conference so in
this case we could talk to him and say
hey look Wolfgang we want to contact
those guys from Azerbaijan with whom you
already know we have ongoing issues or
even more likely he would have
approached us himself and say guys why
don't we get you together the President
of Azerbaijan and the Prime Minister of
Armenia they have a conflict called
Nagorny Karabakh which is been going on
for practically thirty years now where
people are being killed all the time
right not in huge numbers but people
died so yesterday we organized a session
for these two and both of them told me
this is actually the first time we show
up together anywhere because what the
man says and we can tell you this
because one of our team was there and
saw it with his own eyes passion and
Ally EV were arguing together on the
same stage and then you all say I mean
come on Simon eternally mean that to you
leaders you hate each other into the
same German conference hands in hands
and sang kumbaya for a photo opportunity
and now everything is sorted it orally
in fact throughout the debate they
devoted them
to discussing historical dated to
justify why nagorno-karabakh should
belong to one side or the other it was
not a friendly chat but the truth is
that in this type of conference the
least important things of the onstage
debates the real action is what happens
in the cafes and in hotels for that
reason at the Munich Security Conference
the rooms are prepared so the various
delegations can sit down and negotiate
the next time you hear about two
countries that have signed an agreement
think that most likely the agreement was
previously discussed on the sofa of
hotel suite
[Music]
hands as far as the conference was
concerned both the Azerbaijani and
Armenian delegations and more than one
chance to have coffee together and talk
about the situation does this mean
they've already signed a peace
agreements not really but it means it
looks like an agreement could be reached
but in this case I can't show you any
data yet just our personal option yes I
know here a visual politic we'd like to
base everything we say on supporting
facts and statistics not just a few
rumors we've heard but in this case
there's still not much hard evidence in
the meantime I leave you with this
question do you think that Armenia and
Azerbaijan will end up reaching a peace
agreement what were the consequences of
this be for these two countries well
leave your answer in the comments below
also please do visit the your MSC
channel where you can see all the
interviews that we conducted during the
Munich Security Conference you guys see
me in my place is Fonseca who is one of
the presenters on the Spanish Channel so
I really do hope you enjoyed this video
please do check out our fantastic
sponsor and news of ice who I'm linking
to below and thank you for watching if
you want to learn more about politics
and world affairs and here's some more
of my lovely voice come check out the
reconsidered podcast where we don't do
the thinking for you find reconsider @ww
re consider mediacom or on Apple or
Google Play or your favorite podcast
[Music]